each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
in for dr. mesnick's talk on orthopedic
medicine of preventive and holistic
remedies to all of us who are weekend
warriors on the basketball court and
hiking around the the beautiful Puget
Sound I'm so pleased he is able to come
and take the time to talk with us this
afternoon in addition to being on the
faculty at the University of Washington
and teaching at bastyr university he's a
well-traveled speaker and is always
running around the United States trying
to help us all live better lives and so
please help me welcome here this him
this afternoon to Microsoft Research I
assume my mics on can you hear me okay
okay this talk is actually on guidelines
and prescriptions for optimal health for
optimal energy and for optimal brain
function so I'm going to cover a lot of
material that you probably wouldn't even
ordinary here here doctor talk about ok
and a little bit of background on myself
I'm board certified in two fields of
medicine sports medicine and that's the
orthopedic side of things and adult
internal medicine I'm also the author of
this book conditioning for outdoor
fitness with a subtitle of functional
exercise and nutrition for every body
and this is good for anybody who's not
in a coma this book because this book
has so much information not only about
how to exercise and all this new
information about what's called
functional exercise but part 4 is
totally developed to devoted to
nutrition and wellness and has chapters
on women's issues has chapters on
nutrition and exercise for optimal
wellness all kinds of information about
how to stay well and healthy now my talk
is going to include more information
than what's in in this book but it this
book is a great guide for exercise and
nutrition I'm in private practice in
bellevue washington which as you know is
not too far from here and my practice is
a combination of adult medicine but I
take a much more holistic and
integrative approach to prevention of
diseases to improving function and
assessing function optimizing wellness
and dealing with a lot of problems that
a lot of Doc's might just give a drug
for that I get to more the root of the
problem I also do orthopedic medicine
from a non-surgical point of view and I
do a lot with pain management but i also
have specialties and nutrition in
designing exercise programs for people I
see patients with all kinds of
orthopedic problems see patients that
are having trouble sleeping have
insomnia anxiety people want to lose
weight people want to manage weight and
I see patients that just want to stay
healthy and they say I went to my doctor
and they said they did their physical or
in a few labs and then I said well what
else can we do here and the patients are
coming in to see me because they say
that's not enough anymore to just say
well we got a blood test and see you
next year that is not answering a lot of
people's needs on how to stay well and
healthy and prevent diseases so I do a
lot with that this book was published
November of 2004 this is the second
edition but the first edition did not
have a part for and I wanted to write a
completely new book but I was so busy I
didn't have time to find a new publisher
so I asked this publisher if we could
change the title they said no it's too
popular the way it is but you can change
the subtitle to indicate that this book
is now about nutrition and wellness so
we change the subtitle to functional
exercise and nutrition for everybody
it's available at rei in redmond it's
available at most bookstores it's
available on Amazon and that's the phone
number to get it directly from the
publisher ok they'll mail it to
publishers in Seattle now here are some
goals for this talk to give you some
guidelines to be optimally healthy and a
lot of people don't know what being
optimally healthy is ok and I'll try to
educate you a little bit about that
because it's a desirable thing to
exercise smartly to achieve health and
body image goals as well as improved
performance to understand and take
charge of your aging process not many
people know that you can do that
we're all aging and when I was in my 20s
I didn't even think about it and nobody
does but any time you start thinking
about gaining control of your aging
process is the time to do it okay and
I'm going to talk to you about that to
help you have a lot of energy to help
you manage stress and sleep well help
you sharpen your focus and brain
function your memory and your
performance with your mind help you
prevent diseases such as heart attacks
strokes and cancer and help you maintain
or lose weight smartly now what are your
goals every one of you probably has
goals and we unfortunately don't have
time to go around the room and find out
about what each one of your goals are
but I suggest you start opening up a
Microsoft Word file with your health
goals because most people don't have any
health goals but if you have a file on
your laptop or someplace and start
expanding your health goals that will
actually help you improve your health
okay I get a file I got a word document
that's my own health goals and I am
adding to it occasionally but they've
been pretty refined for a while so do
you want to be healthy forever that's a
desirable goal because you know what
happens to most people that I see and
most people that I hear about from other
doctors they're healthy until age who
knows what 40 45 42 and then it starts
to go a little bit downhill and they
lose their energy they're not sleeping
as well they don't feel as vital that
brain doesn't work as well they can't
remember things as well and eventually
and get cancer and heart attacks that's
not desirable the desirable thing is to
be so healthy and well that you live to
be a hundred ten and all of a sudden you
go on a hike or something that your god
that's it and that was a great life not
all this suffering and ability brain
function problems the whole thing it's
not it's not the way to go so being
healthy forever that's a good goal do
you want to look younger than you are
that's actually possible you can take a
person who's 40 that looks 60 and a
person who's 40 who looks 35 now when
we're 20 we want to look older but as we
get a little older we want to look
younger okay so do you want to look
younger than you are do you want to have
a brain that functions at high
agency for as long as possible i know
you all want to have computers that
function at high efficiency for as long
as possible but brains that are
functioning at high efficiency that's
desirable how about being mentally sharp
indefinitely that's desirable having a
lot of energy and not burning out then
the question is are you taking charge of
these goals are you saying I need to
organize these goals and make sure these
things happen as opposed to just relying
on my quote unquote primary care
provider to make sure these things
happen because these aren't the goals of
your primary care provider I don't know
if you notice that but they're not and
about 12 years ago I expanded my
horizons because I was tired of having
limited goals for patients which was
basically you know do you have a disease
or a symptom let me see if I can help
you today with that and that that
unfortunately was the limit of most
goals okay so the average doctor that
you see does not have these goals
unfortunately a conventional model of
health and disease is relatively
simplistic and linear your body is quite
complex though very complex many
internal systems that are very
interrelated but unfortunately in
medicine we have all these specialists
and oftentimes these systems in your
body are not seen as so interrelated ok
so the health of your brain and your
body is a relative thing and it's really
on a continuum it's on a continuum of
function and wellness and you can take
charge of your body's functional
potential the word functional means
there's a functional spectrum of how
well things are working okay you can
take charge of preventing cancer strokes
heart attacks and dementia and did you
know that the time to start preventing
these things is now but you can optimize
your function you know if you're like in
your 20s and 30s and said I don't care
about heart attacks and strokes that
doesn't happen for a while well do you
care about good brain function do you
hear that you musculoskeletal system
works good do you care that you know
you're relaxed in your brains working
good so there's a lot of things that you
could do functionally now so try to
avoid taking your body for granted most
people take their bodies for grant it's
like okay I get this car I'm going to
drive it into the ground but
unfortunately with cars you can get a
new model but you can't quite get a
whole new body can get a few parts
replaced but not as much as we'd like so
we don't want to take
our bodies for granted we want to take
charge of our bodies do things that can
be really helpful along the way and it's
not that many things that you that I'm
going to have to tell you to do okay so
what's optimal health excellent energy
clear thinking good mood okay excellent
cardiovascular fitness strengthen muscle
mass to have a normal metabolism but
also to look good look the way you want
to and to minimize your chance of having
injuries with doing the sports and
activities you like and be free or
relatively free from vessel diseases in
your heart in your brain it's also to be
free from troubling symptoms from your
inner organs and your joints and muscles
okay it's also to sleep well and of
course have good relationships and be
involved and have a healthy environment
for fresh air clean water and healthy
food i wish i could say they've just
took charge your body everything will be
fine but we still need healthy water and
food and things that were not totally
under control of so our medical system
what's the deal with our medical system
it's oriented towards disease management
there's linear thinking if you have this
I give you that that type of thinking I
got tired of about twelve to fourteen
years it was just too boring for me I
said I'm not keen on just every time
someone comes in if you get this I give
you that and I don't know you've all
experienced it and it's not complex
enough it's not web-like enough to
really say how to improve your function
prevention is usually limited to
cholesterol only some cancer screening
and checking for signs of disease and
the end result is a high instance of
people being fatigued in our society a
high incidence of people being depressed
having poor memory poor brain function
more rapid aging heart disease strokes
and cancer and they say that we're
paying too much money for health care
and that you know in the future not too
long we won't even be able to afford the
amount of money we're paying that's
because we're not preventing an
optimizing function as well as we can so
why is the medical care system like this
well most docs aren't keeping up with
the literature and the research it's
hard to keep up with a literature in the
research what I do to keep up with the
literature
the researchers I organized a group of
doctors that meets once a month on
Mercer Island and we bring in a lecture
of the state-of-the-art lecturer the
other thing I do is I read three
articles a day on the stair climber I
get on one of those stairmasters you
know that you walk on and I read the
articles and that's the best way I can
keep up with things did you know it
takes an average of eight to ten years
for a well-researched recommendation to
be incorporated by the average doctor
that's why if after this lecture you
went into your doctor said dr. small I
want you to get some tests that I heard
about they're called homocysteine in
lipoprotein little a in CRP dr. small
even though the literature came out
seven years ago may still not be up with
it may still not have been incorporated
because the research shows eight to ten
years to incorporate this the other
thing is a doctor is unlikely to order a
test unless they know what to do with
the result but if they order your
homeless cysteine test and they don't
know how to control your homocysteine to
reduce your risk of heart disease with B
vitamins they won't order the test
because they don't know what to do about
it okay okay so this is a few things
most medical schools and medical schools
in general don't educate doctors how to
write exercise prescriptions they don't
tell them how to do lifestyle changes
how to improve sleep and stress
management and they don't believe it or
not teach doctors about nutrition or
supplements and so you're just in
general it's hard to get that
information the only way you're going to
get it from a doctor's if they went to
naturopathic school and really learn the
stuff were there a medical doctor that
is really taking extra trading in this
material that's the only way to get it
now there is a different model which is
called functional medicine that
submerged about 12 years ago and it's a
whole field of medicine that's evolved
which involves thinking about cell and
organ function and looking at the
interrelationships between your immune
system your gastrointestinal system the
blood vessels the inflammation all these
things in the body that are
interrelating now what is aging but
losing structural integrity and function
at different rates and that's what we
want to sort of get a handle on so aging
is very complex
there's a limited number of cell
divisions that your cells can do anyway
and tissues decrease in their ability to
repair themselves over time well why do
we think that people start getting more
diseases after age 40 heart problems
vessel problems arthritis these all
these things are starting to decrease
and function so aging is a combination
of damage to your DNA damage to sell an
organ function and free radical damage
free radicals are these extra electrons
that you've probably heard about and
there's the free radical theory of aging
extra electrons are looking for an
electron to pair up with and in doing so
they will damaged tissues and cells in
the body they come from air pollution
your body makes someone you exercise
they come from toxins that you consume
and your foods they come from all kinds
of places and toxin accumulation from
PCBs pesticides mercury all these things
that you're getting exposed to can
damage cells and speed up the aging
process so what we have with aging is
degeneration of structure and function
at different rates your blood vessels
may be doing this at one rate your
joints may be doing this at another rate
and the goal is to slow it down and
manage it so you're as healthy as
possible now how about your
musculoskeletal system your your muscles
your bones etc what's aging there one
part of aging is osteoporosis which is
bone density changes but another part
which is really interesting is the loss
of muscle and this loss of muscle has
been documented every 10 years you can
lose almost ten percent on the muscle on
your body that's the that's what's sort
of been shown unless people do something
about this have you ever seen an older
person in their 70s that looks really
fragile and frail do you know why they
look like that because they've lost too
much muscle and they're sort of hobbling
around and they've lost bone and so
they're sort of like this my grandmother
looked like that that was my early
picture of what aging looked like and I
said I never want to do this this just
does not look fun she even had trouble
getting up and down a chair but did she
exercise no she doesn't now my mother's
older than her and I
on an exercise program she's been
exercising for a long time so one thing
we want to do to slow down the aging
process is to keep muscle on your body
and actually build it okay so you can
take charge of your aging process you
can optimize and protect your vital
systems and you can prevent the
degeneration of your mind and your blood
vessels or you can at least slow it down
but the time to start is now okay so
here's some general recommendations I
have for doing this okay getting eight
hours of sleep is pretty darn important
sleep is a regenerative function there
are so many biochemical things that
happened during sleep that are so
important you know if you don't get
enough sleep you're a little irritable
you can start getting fatigued but if
people really don't get enough sleep for
a while you can start aching all over
their body there's lots of things that
can go on so it is important in general
to get eight hours of sleep on a regular
basis and we have what's called a sleep
deficit if you don't get eight hours of
sleep on the average you will build up a
sleep deficit and if you don't make it
up on the weekends you'll have even more
of a sleep deficit now the studies show
you can't make all of it up if you're
completely sleep-deprived but you can
make some of it up and I do recommend
trying to make some of it up each week
especially if you're working a lot
you've got projects that are happening
you got to get something out soon I
recommend trying to make up the sleep
deficit because otherwise it can lead to
some harmful effects I've had patients
that were so stressed out and didn't
sleep for a while they were working so
much that they ended up compromising
their rien system getting a bad virus
that ending up with some real problems
so the sleep thing is really important
then optimizing your cellular energy
production in your mitochondria your
mitochondria the places inside your cell
that make the ATP that make the energy
and I used to think they they would
never come out with an ATP bar and it's
true they still haven't come out with an
ATP bar but you have to make sure that
you're doing things to make sure these
mitochondria work properly and I'll talk
about that a little bit more but part of
this is getting enough calories so
you're not going without breakfast in
luncheon for five hours without eating
and also getting proper mixes of protein
and carbohydrates so that your blood
sugar stays reasonable so you're not
depriving yourselves and your brain of
glucose but there's other things to do
to optimize your cellular energy then
you want to limit inflammation you've
probably all heard about this but
inflammation is now thought as one of
the common pathways for dementia heart
disease and cancer one of the questions
is how inflamed are you and i'm not
talking about irritable i'm talking
about how inflamed is your body okay
because you want to limit that but did
you know that the standard American diet
abbreviated SI d causes inflammation it
causes inflammation why because there's
lots of fried foods there's deep fried
foods there's a imbalance of fats
there's a lot of things in the food that
aren't necessarily good for you there's
the trans fats which you should avoid
these different things the standard
American diet cause inflammation so if
you want to decrease your inflammation
and decrease your risk of these
functional problems and diseases you do
have to modify how you're eating
inflammation is a cellular process in
your body that has to do with usually
the white cell reactions to certain
stimuli the clearest thing about that
you can think of is if you sprain your
ankle there's an inflammatory process
that goes on temporarily the leads to
swelling to sort of ward off the area
but if you got sick with a virus or a
bacteria there'd be an inflammation
process that would try to kill the virus
or bacteria it's a general cellular
mechanism to deal with certain things in
the body but it's very harmful if it
goes out of control it's okay for short
periods of time but on a cellular level
I'd have to talk with you personally to
to give you more information because it
gets very technical okay you know your
stuff would you do one of those scans
okay I'll talk to you about that because
it's coming up about how to measure
inflammation yeah okay so the other
thing to manage aging is minimize you
toxin intake now toxins are chemicals
that your body is not does not have in
your body normally and did you know
there's a figure now that you could be
exposed to any one of 70,000 chemicals
on an average day from either air
pollution remodeling stuff in your house
the products use around your house but
what's in your food I couldn't believe
it was up to 70,000 your body has to
take these chemicals bio transform them
in your liver and try to get them either
out in your urine or in your bowel
movements and if it can't do it guess
where it goes goes in your brain it goes
and your fat cells goes in other places
too so and and these things are related
to cancer because now it's felt that
seventy eighty percent of cancer is
what's called environmentally induced
environmentally induced means toxin
damage to DNA etc so it is a really good
idea to slow the aging process down to
minimize toxins that's why in chapter 26
I talked about how to do it but I do
encourage people to start out with good
healthy fruits and vegetables and
eventually try to pick organic fruits
and vegetables when they can and the
free-range meats because there's less
toxins in those foods as well as to do
things when you remodel and the products
used around their home to minimize the
the toxins you're using okay there's
other goals like improving methylation
that is a very complex biochemical thing
that can be done but B vitamins and
maintain a healthy immune system and
limit viral infections the best way to
maintain a healthy immune system is
getting enough rest and eating a healthy
balanced diet and doing some certain
things when you go on planes because the
the place you're most likely to get some
of these things is with the air
circulating on on planes okay what about
by eating what can you do by the way you
eat to try to get a little more improved
function or healthy or so eating a
healthy diet to provide
phytochemicals for detoxification
phytochemicals are things in your food
that are healthy chemicals now I'm going
to go into this a little bit later but
the best way to do this is to eat fruits
and vegetables of all different colors
and I have a slide later on about this
call it eating from the rainbow
literally and there's a great book
called the color code written in 2003 of
all the research that's been done most
of it's been done at Tufts University
Medical School they've analyzed
practically every fruit and vegetable
and looked at ones that are the best
antioxidants I couldn't believe this
when they set prunes have the most in
hours I said okay fine but I'm not doing
that okay but kidney beans did you know
kidney beans have some of the best
antioxidants in them I started choosing
kidney beans at the salad bar just
because of that whereas originally go
those look weird i'm not taking those
things but I'm suggesting you start
eating not only with your mind but also
with some knowledge because the waist
just eating is you choose foods both on
the basis of file they look how they
taste and how healthy they are and some
people say oh but that's not going to
taste very good I don't eat food that
doesn't taste good all the food I eat
tastes good because I don't like eating
food that doesn't taste good but it's
it's more than the healthy side of
things so you want to eat adequate
protein and we'll talk about that and
you want to actually incorporate healthy
fat it's been said that there's a very
big imbalance in terms of the kind of
fat that people are getting one of the
most healthy things you could do is
start reading labels and avoid anything
that says partially hydrogenated those
have been linked to heart disease and
problems of the brain and inflammation
if you shop at Whole Foods in bellevue
they say that they don't have any trans
fats in anything and I actually teach
classes there cooking classes because my
patients said how to make this healthy
food and I said I don't know I guess
we're going to have to teach a cooking
class so now I teach a class called the
doctor and the chef meets every other
month I'm the doctor i educate about
some topic the chef starts cooking and
people start eating so I got a lot more
used to what's going on at Whole Foods
and I tried my best to find unhealthy
trans fats I walked every Ally couldn't
find anything
with it so you know that's sort of a
no-brainer for able to get over there
they have everything from Oreos to
anything you want there's no trans fats
in any of their stuff there so we don't
need trans fats anymore in the food
supply but the food lobby is so strong
it's still in most foods it's even in
most protein bars and the way you avoid
it is it says partially hydrogenated and
then there's some oil listed and that's
what you don't want okay you do want
some good omega-3s and I'll talk about
that you can get that in walnuts so
healthy snack is actually walnuts and
macadamia nuts and mixed nuts mixed nuts
has actually been shown in studies to
help prevent heart disease but you want
to get the mixed nuts that don't have
msg and glutamate sinem just regular
mixed nuts okay also omega-3s are very
healthy and I think I have another slide
about this hopefully I do because I want
to talk about that because a lot of
people are confused about that then you
want quality carbs for energy so many
people are thinking I can't have any
carbohydrates through the low carb diet
or the south beach diet or this or that
it's hard to get enough calories to
support your body in a day if you don't
eat any carbohydrates so what I suggest
is that you choose healthy carbohydrates
as opposed to unhealthy ones the
unhealthy ones are the quick sugars in
the candy and you know but I am an
advocate of dark chocolate it's got very
good antioxidants if you're not sense of
chocolates it can be a good food but
these quick you know the donuts and some
of these things of these quick starches
are not good for you they put on
calories but there's lots of good breads
that you can buy out there you can make
grains as a matter of fact the next
doctor and chef class I just found out I
found out i'm teaching monday the 23rd
at Whole Foods in bellevue is on cooking
and incorporating healthy grains and
fiber in your diet it's almost a full
dinner too that's Monday the 23rd okay
so fiber for colon health fiber 25 to 35
grams per day it's tough to get that's
why the chef at this place said dr.
buzzer you gotta help us figure out how
to help people get that mount mount of
fiber in their diet because people say
they can't do it fiber is important for
colon cancer prevention and colon
cancers
and the major killers in this country
and people can start getting that after
age 40 there's nothing that says you
can't get it you know you have to wait
till you're 70 to get colon cancer no we
have to keep our colons healthy and one
very interesting thing most people don't
think about keeping this healthy have
any of you thought about what's below
here and above here and then why do I
need to keep this healthy well one
reason is did you know sixty percent of
your immune system is in here sixty
percent so if you're inflamed in here or
it's sensitive or you got a lot of gas
or bloating your stuff going on here i
call it SGO stuff going on but if you've
got s gos down here then you can have
more inflammation in your body or if you
got inflammation in your colon because
there's lots of imbalances you're a more
at risk for colon cancer when is fiber
how or why how or why okay there's two
types of fiber soluble and insoluble the
insoluble the easiest way to think about
that is the the wheat bran and the wheat
bran cereals I think of that more as a
steam shovel approach getting the files
out of your body and you know it most
people don't know well how many bowel
movements should I have per day what's
healthy you know I've i've had people
guessed well probably once every other
two days three days no like one or two a
day sizable quantities get that stuff
moving through your body on a regular
basis because things can get recycled in
there soluble fiber absorbs things
soluble fibers like oatmeal beans beans
are actually incredibly healthy for your
colon they're soluble fiber so that's
another thing they're not only
antioxidants but they're soluble fiber
so it's a combination those
recommendations for 25 to 35 grams of
fiber is a combo of soluble and
insoluble the best way to get it to tell
you the truth is for breakfast to eat a
breakfast cereal on an almost daily
basis with like an a brand cereal and
you don't have to do the purebred you
could mix it with some other things and
then deed a couple apples a day and then
the five to seven servings of fruits and
vegetables there's a lot of ways to get
it but most the ways to get it is that
way okay and there's some extremely
healthy bread
out there there's a bread that I eat now
from a bakery called french bakery you
can get it a whole foods or PCC it's got
five grams of protein and five grams of
fiber in each slice and it tastes good
which is amazing because if you don't
want to eat breakfast here you can just
put some almond butter on that or
something okay now more food choice
issues too to maintain your blood sugar
for optimal energy and brain function
you don't want to have your blood sugar
dip and way down you want to eat
breakfast a lot of people skip breakfast
and you know what the average breakfast
is in this country from professionals a
cup of coffee and a scone that does not
keep the blood sugar up very long or you
know we could go around the room and
find out what the average professional
breakfast is in this country here but I
tell you there's not very much protein
in it the effect of eating protein with
breakfast is it helps keep your blood
sugar up over time and did you know your
body needs a certain amount of protein a
day and if you don't eat it do you know
where it takes it from your muscles it
eats the muscles okay so your body takes
out muscle that's why you don't want to
be trying to keep your muscle on your
body and not eating breakfast and lunch
you're not getting protein so the
average breakfast is this Conan some
coffee the average lunch is what a salad
that's the average female professionals
lunch guys do salads and some other
things but there's so most people aren't
getting enough protein at breakfast and
lunch their blood sugars are dipping
down and what do people do in their
blood Sugar's dip down they go for the
quick things you know the quick snacks
the quick carbs that's where people are
craving things like most cravings are
related to low blood sugars now so
what's what's a good breakfast either
that brand cereal and having something
else with more protein like mixed i
believe i take mixed nuts and put it in
the bran cereal but the other thing is
making yourself a protein smoothie a lot
of my pages I don't have time to make
breakfast I go if you don't have time I
don't have time and I make a time which
is to make a smoothie so this protein
smoothie is pretty easy and I get that
recipe on the next slide here
the other thing you want to do is you
want to aid detoxification for how you
eat how many of you going to the salad
bar or saying what do I have to have for
vegetables and you're saying yourself I
got to get the bad stuff out of my body
and the way I'm going to do this is to
aid my liver by eating some broccoli or
some kale or some leeks and these things
are extremely healthy they've been shown
to prevent cancer they help you liver
bio transform chemicals that shouldn't
be in there and I advocate that people
eat something from that broccoli
cauliflower cabbage kale family every
day as well as something from the leak
onion garlic family every day because it
really helps your body and if you
haven't cooked with leeks try it it's
very tasty very good stuff what you do
is slice them in little slices and steam
them mix them with other vegetables stir
fry them with omelets or whatever very
healthy stuff then when you're eating
say gee I need to have things of
different colors because the different
colors have different phytochemicals in
them so you want the Reds the Greens the
purples the yellow orange the purple
things have been shown to help your
brain the purple things have been shown
to help the bread blood-brain barrier
stay safe do you know that you have a
blood brain barrier in your brain and
its job is to keep things out of your
brain that shouldn't go in there okay I
mean there's someone trying to keep me
out of here unless I had the right
credentials so there's a blood brain
barrier that tries to keep things out
you want to strengthen that blood brain
barrier you want to protect it and you
want to decrease inflammation and
oxidation and free radicals in the brain
and the best way to do it believe it or
not is to eat blueberries but organic
blueberries because most berries are
sprayed with pesticides so you can get
frozen organic blueberries you put half
a scoop in your smoothie you can now get
them of course when you go to the store
but blueberries blackberries those
darkly colored berries all the different
berries are very healthy for both your
brain and your heart and I was very
pleased to see there's a company called
Lakewood that makes juices you can get
them at PCC and whole foods they just
came out with what I think is one of the
most amazing antioxidant juices it's
called pomegranate
a heart healthy or something and it's
got blueberry pomegranate all these
phytochemicals in it and it tastes good
it tastes good so I recommend if you
like juice that you get that because
there's not a lot of sugar in that but
it's really good for your brain in the
rest of your body okay what about
protein needs now how do you figure out
how much protein you need you need point
8 grams per kilogram of lean body mass
now lean body mass is the amount you
would weigh if you're in your perfect
weight whatever you'd think that perfect
weight would be and unless you're really
overweight most you're probably close to
lean body mass but people that are
overweight have to say okay what would I
way if I was really at my lean body mass
okay but you need more protein if you're
exercising you need if you're exercising
aerobic li the way i recommend which is
five to six days a week cardiovascular
exercise for at least 30 minutes you
need about a gram per kilogram now
remember you take your weight in pounds
and divide it by 2.2 and you get the
kilograms okay I always talk about the
average 70 kilogram person needs 70
grams of protein but if you're really
training quite a bit for something like
for a marathon or or seattle to portland
or something else you need about 1.2
grams of protein and if your
bodybuilding and really trying to put
more muscle on and really form a lot
more muscle you might need a little bit
more protein so I've got some other
information here breakfast free-range
eggs with veggies most people don't have
time to make that except on the weekend
or cereal and nuts or nut butters or
protein smoothie now for a protein
smoothie the average scoop of protein
powder has 15 grams of protein so if you
take a scoop and a half you'll get about
20 to 23 grams if you start the day with
at least that amount of protein you're
going to at least have a chance to
getting the protein you need okay and
then you mix that with eight to ten
ounces of the fluid of your choice okay
except for soda pop don't mix it with
soda pop and then some type of berries
or banana i recommend the berries
because you might as well get those good
phytochemicals
first thing in the morning and I'll give
you 20 22 25 grams of protein now what
kind of protein do you want to buy that
gets tricky okay my feeling is some of
the best protein is is way because way
can help the immune system so if you
want to benefit I like to multitask I
like to benefit my immune system benefit
my brain and get enough protein all in
the same drink that you know that's
multitasking one type of multitasking
okay so it you cannot really find
organic way in most stores if you can
buy it but you got to look and see what
they say about what the cows are doing
because the average count in this
country is not that healthy so it's nice
to get organic way and I have a source
listed here if you want to get organic
way there's a company that only sells
the doctors but I can get people a
source for it if they email me I'm not
going to give out that information now
but if you're interested they have
organic way this particular company and
the other thing is how do you find a
protein bar that's really healthy
remember when you look at a protein bar
if you're going to use protein bars to
augment your protein you want to see
number one how much protein is in there
I wanted to destroy the other day and it
said protein bar there's four grams in
the bar and I thought that's ridiculous
because it's mostly carbohydrates you
want at least 12 grams in a protein bar
ideally 12 to 15 grams you want it to be
tasty you wanted to have no partially
hydrogenated oils it would be nice if it
at a few vitamins and minerals okay so
there is a source of protein bars that I
listed here it's called ultra lean low
carb bars with the same company another
source is cliff bars Clif bars are
fairly reasonable they sell them in a
lot of places whole foods now has them
for 99 cents which is better some store
selling for a buck 70 and that's kind of
outrageous but cliff bars are pretty
reasonable in terms of the amount of
protein and how pure they are they're
pretty reasonable I forget how much
protein is in them okay let's talk about
protein purity and toxins animal protein
is most likely to be contaminated with
things that you don't want to be taking
in that's why it's better to choose free
range chicken or free-range turkey or
free range of beef
okay because otherwise it concentrates
up the food chain also you want to limit
or eliminate your intake of large fish
because large fish like tuna swordfish
have a lot of mercury mercury is not
good for your brain or your nervous
system oui oui some of us have it in our
mouths i recommend do not get any more
amalgam fillings if you got any don't
get any more and if you have kids i
recommend against them get the types of
feelings that are just the color of your
teeth okay there's a lot of information
on that and i'll talk to people
individually about that but i don't
recommend getting any more of these but
i also recommend limiting your mercury
intake from your fish used to be said
eat salmon every week because a study
came out that said if you eat salmon
once a week there's less chance of heart
attacks that gets the tricky
recommendation i'd say if you want to
eat salmon make sure it's wild salmon as
the farm salmon of PCBs which is a toxic
chemical and I don't know how it's
getting into the farm salmon but it is
but the farm Salmons are basically along
the coast and they're doing certain
things that aren't as healthy okay in
terms of dairy if you consume dairy
which is cheese and milk and all this
try to choose organic dairy products I
know it costs a little bit more but it
is healthier you can get them in every
grocery store now horizon makes them
there's lots of companies it is
healthier I realized there aren't as
many choices for ice cream but you can
get organic ice cream too okay and
there's lots of sources of vegetarian
protein if any of your vegetarian
there's lots of different sources i
listed here combining grains and legumes
beans eggs etc nuts all kinds of things
now fat guidelines for good health we
want to minimize the trans fats I talked
about that you want to minimize
saturated fats you know the difference
between regular ice cream and low fat
ice cream is pretty significant in terms
of the saturated fat issue but you want
to think about incorporating omega-3s in
your daily routine why because omega-3s
including the EPA and DHA and the
omega-3s have been the most studied
intervention other than exercise if you
said to me
things can improve health have been most
studied by research I'd say exercise and
omega-3s if you do a Google search on
either one of those topics you're going
to find a lot of hits on either one of
those topics with research articles now
the studies have shown that one gram
official per day helps mood couple grams
helps decrease inflammation couple grams
a day helps decrease the plaques in the
heart and have you ever heard of it
anybody having a sudden heart attack the
reason sudden heart attacks happen is
because of plaque rupture those are
inflammatory Pat plaques so EPA can help
that too and then the DHA how many of
you have kids here that are less than 15
raise your hand DHA is essential for
brain development you know it's now in
formulas it's an omega-3 it's required
in most formulas now because it's
essential for brain development but it's
essential until the kid is a full-grown
teenager and then a PA is a good idea so
pregnant women should be taking DHA
lactating women breastfeeding women and
then the kids themselves as soon as they
they can take the DHA they should be
taken in themselves and studies have
shown you have a smart kid more likely
to succeed at Microsoft Hills or just
oil for us to have them in food
it's hard to get enough omega-3 s unless
you supplement with it or unless you eat
the fish the problem is i thought the
mercury comes to the fish that's i'm now
recommending that people actually
supplement with the omega-3s because if
you and if you supplement with omega-3
is either the capsule form and there's
liquid you want to make sure that the
bottle says this product has been tested
and been shown to be free of mercury
PCBs and pesticides otherwise don't buy
that product okay so there's there's
certain officials that are tested for
that or purified for that insert a lot
of them aren't but flaxseed oil does not
work the same flaxseed oil isn't omega-3
but it has to be converted by an enzyme
system and there's only about eighteen
percent efficiency so you can get it as
a vegetarian you can't get omega-3s but
you have to take a lot of flaxseed oil
and walnuts remember you can't heat
flaxseed oil you can't cook with it you
just pour it on stuff
okay carb guidelines use healthy complex
carbs as opposed to the quick carbs and
you know we all eat quick carbs i was
teaching in san diego this weekend and
at a hospital and we went down and
someone said oh you want to eat lunch at
three trench bakery I said I don't eat
those kind of carbs they said check this
place out so I did they had the most
amazing almond scone I have ever had in
my life so I had a bunch of those carbs
so I I eat that those kind of carbs I'd
call that high quality hi Carl quality
unhealthy carbs as opposed to the low
quality bakery but what I'm suggesting
is you incorporate good quality complex
carbohydrates in your diet like beans at
the salad bar really good breads like
this one I'm talking about you more of
the whole grain breads the cereals cliff
bars have good carbs in them and that
you actually learn how to make grains
and legumes that are actually healthy
you can actually make a side dish at
home not only a brown rice but you can
make a side dish of like me millet
quinoa some of these grains are
extremely tasty just boil them for 15
minutes in a special little thing and
it's done it gives you some calories and
especially if you're exercising every
day you got to replace the glycogen and
your muscles why don't I take questions
at the end it would be easier because I
still want to go through a lot of
material here okay let's talk about
arthritis and joint support somebody
came up to me today said I've got some
issues and part of my body one of my
joints isn't so good are you going to
talk about that join us and I can't talk
about every joint in the body but I will
talk about joint support with nutrients
some of us weekend warriors or whatever
have gotten injured okay and then we got
some what we call degenerative joint
changes which means the joints a little
thinner it's not working as well it
hurts whatever even though it's called
the generative joint disease or djd it's
not really a disease what it means is a
particular joint like your hip or knee
area ankle has the cartilage injured and
is now not as wide or as normal as it
should be now there's lots of things to
do about it sometimes orthotics help in
your shoes good shoe where is essential
okay and then there's a supplement
cosa mean sulfate that's been shown in
numerous studies to help support the
support the joint lining 1500 milligrams
supports the joint lining so I recommend
people take that if they have any
degenerative changes that they want to
support and there's no side effects from
the stuff you need to take it eight to
ten weeks before it really starts
working and I would avoid regular
chondroitin sulfate it's in most of
these joint support supplements but
guess where it's from cow windpipes and
I don't think that's a healthy source
right now so I would recommend if you're
going to take glucosamine sulfate to
support your joints make sure it's pure
glucosamine sulfate that's what's in it
most bottles people bring in their
bottles whenever anybody makes the point
with me they come in with a bag of their
supplements and I analyze them and say
this is appropriate or this is not as
good as you can be doing and most people
aren't taking glucosamine sulfate their
joint support supplements have a lot of
other stuff in it but not that so that
is important now keep your eye on
vitamin D that's an interesting vitamin
it's been lately a lot of information
everybody used to think vitamin D was
just for bones it's now fought the
vitamin D receptors have now been found
on every cell practically in your body
do you know what that means vitamin D is
not just for bones it's now felt to be
important in cancer prevention cancer
prevention with vitamin D nobody would
have thought that so I recommend people
take at least 400 units per day a
vitamin D and you can get that in a lot
of multiple vitamins or if not take it
now guess how much vitamin D you make on
an average day if you walk out in short
sleeves and shorts if it's sunny and
this is only from may until September
around here in San Diego it's different
but we're in the northern latitude you
make twenty thousand international units
within 20 minutes of being exposed to
the Sun that's pretty good so on days
when you do that and I'm not advocating
you you know I'm not advocating you
expose yourself to the Sun okay because
i don't want some dermatologists calling
me up and say oh my god what do you tell
you is people to do i'm just saying that
we do get vitamin
he threw our skin unless you lather your
whole body up with the factor 15 or
something and it is healthy but not to
burn you know just a little bit it is
healthy it's in it's essential during
the winter so to supplement with vitamin
D is essential during the winter from
October through April okay and it can
even help your mood okay so exercise is
really critical for good health you want
to do both aerobic and strength training
and exercise is the most well researched
thing that has ever been shown to
improve health now if you exercise
cardiovascularly 30 minutes in your
target heart rate zone five to six days
a week you can potentially achieve the
following benefits you can decrease your
risk of fatal heart attacks in half
that's huge fatal means dying so that's
huge okay all right you know my patients
say to me you know I can't really relate
to a heart attack I say well that's when
your heart gets partially damaged or the
other time you can't relate to a heart
attack is when you're dead okay so
either partial heart damage or enough so
you can't even be alive anymore and I
say the thing you don't want is to be in
the coronary care unit looking at all
these monitors and stuff you want to be
visiting someone in there that's fine
you don't want to be in there yourself
right so exercise is essential it will
cut your risk of strokes by forty
percent what's a stroke a few body
doesn't work that's not very desirable
okay hard to work on your keyboard then
if after your body doesn't work okay it
actually cuts the risk of colon cancer
and it improves your immunity sleep
blood pressure and cholesterol so lots
of benefits from cardiovascular exercise
but how do you design your program to
get these benefits five to six days a
week you want to be doing it you want to
be in your target heart rate zone for 30
minutes but that being said even taking
a walk at a break for 15 minutes is
helpful so if you took two 15-minute
walks today it would still get close to
it but it doesn't quite get in the
intensity issues
now your target heart rate zone is your
max heart rate we can be calculated as
220 minus your age so for 40 year old
person that would be 180 that would be
their estimated max heart rate and then
you multiply it times seventy percent
that's the low level of your heart rate
and eighty percent it's eighty-five
percent high level so it takes few
minutes to warm up but eventually you
want to be in that zone of heart rate
that's when the benefits are the most
know how do you know if you're in that
zone you feel like you're working pretty
hard but you're not going to fall off
the equipment or fall on the floor and
the aerobics class or something but you
feel like you're working tonight and
most people are going to sweat doing
this okay I say to people if you're not
sweating you're probably not working
hard enough ok so the zone is a little
lower if you want to lose weight it's
sixty to seventy percent if you want to
lose weight why because more fat burning
occurs in that zone ok but you got to do
it longer if you want to lose weight you
got to do it for 45 minutes to an hour
that's why a committee came out with
recommendations in the newspaper I don't
know if you remember this but it was
three or four months ago sometime is
that the average American should be
exercising one hour a day that was the
average overweight American it didn't
overturn this this business okay now
what if you want to really achieve some
high level performance then maybe you
want to do interval training okay so let
me tell you what it is interval training
is bursts of 30 seconds all the way up
to four minutes of higher intensity
exercise it could be done to improve
your performance it can be done to help
you lose more weight or if you're busy
professional you say hey I want to burn
as many calories in 20 minutes as some
people burn in 30 minutes six do
interval training and what you do is you
got to have 8 to 12 weeks of regular you
know established cardiovascular fitness
and say okay now I'm ready for intervals
you've got to not have any heart disease
in your family or be screened for any
risk of heart disease if your age 40
because the interval training is a bit
more risky and you can't have any
orthopedic problems from your back down
your feet because speeding things up can
aggravate things and then what you do is
say okay let's say you're on the
Stairmaster or you're running say okay
going to do an interval and you decide
to go pretty fast for 30 seconds to a
minute and then you back down to your
zone and it's sort of like this bleep
bleep bleep most programs on your cardio
equipment don't do this they take your
like lunar landing from way low and way
high and they're not reasonable you want
to have a program if you're going to do
an interval program on a cardio piece of
equipment that takes you through your
zone and just bleep sup from the zone
and back down so the best type of
interval training is just you do an
interval every time you feel like it but
you say today's my interval day I'm
going to do it for you know 20 to 30
minutes but I'm going to do five to
seven intervals anywhere from 30 seconds
to 2 minutes but don't do interval
training on consecutive days it's too
difficult on your body try it when you
eventually want to try it if you do do
it no more than two days a week okay and
it can be done for weight loss too so
that's the information in chapter 3 of
my book has all different types of
intervals that you could try chapter 3
of the book is all on cardiovascular
training and interval training okay what
about strength training it's important
it can help you tone it can help you
shape it can help you improve your
resting metabolic rate do you know that
if they locked you in a room at
Microsoft and let you go to the bathroom
but never exercised you would still burn
calories of course and you burn calories
according to what's called you resting
metabolic rate if you just sit there
brain dead at the computer you couldn't
even think anywhere you just SAT there
you'd still burn calories you need a
certain number of calorie-burning to
keep your organs alive that is so
related to whether you can lose weight
or not because if your resting metabolic
rate is too low in the number of
calories you need and you eat too many
calories you're going to gain weight and
if your resting metabolic rate goes up
you can lose weight string Training puts
muscle on your body and helps your
resting metabolic rate go up so either
it helps you lose weight or you can eat
more stuff you like eating say you like
maintaining your weight you can put more
muscle on your body it also slows the
age-related muscle loss that I talked
about basic program is strength training
what you want to think about
is doing things for your upper body like
bicep curls triceps extensions two sets
of 12 will be pretty good in terms of
maintaining your strength three times a
week is needed to build strength to
strength training sessions a week is
needed to maintain what you got you also
want to do like a chest press a lat pull
to the front a row and some basic ab
work now most ab work is just the
crunches and it's not very helpful you
want to do some ab work where you're
sitting and rotating because did you
know most of the things your abs do is
function while you're standing up or
skiing or walking whatever they work to
balance you so there's exercises in this
book called functional abdominal
exercises that work your abs like
they're really used in real life ok it
has been shown that if you exercise the
big muscles on your body such as your
chest your upper back your thighs and
your butt to three sets of ten to
fatigue which means the last rep and set
you really you can do it but you're
struggling a little bit you will secrete
growth hormone at night more than you
usually do that slows the aging process
I don't see anybody here that didn't
have enough growth hormone when you were
a baby you know what you would have
looked like if you didn't have enough
then you'd be a really but as we
get older we lose growth hormone it
starts going down and this is one way
straight training to increase growth
hormone because growth hormone increases
muscle and it also decreases sagging and
wrinkles I know about you but I don't
necessarily want a lot of sagging and
wrinkles I don't think anybody does so
string training can also help with that
now we also want to incorporate
functional exercise what's functional
exercise it incorporates different
regions of the body at the same time but
it also works with gravity okay and it
also works for balance and it works your
core that's what functional exercise is
if you go into a gym and you sit on a
machine and extend your knee that's not
functional exercise it isolates one
joint works one muscle and doesn't work
the way these these legs usually work so
if you if you
out skiing or hiking or do something I
wonder why my legs aren't working as
well as I want them to I go in the gym
and I do this because that's not
functional okay so part of the emphasis
of this book is functional exercise in
part two of this book goes over every
region of your body from your chest to
your butt your abs has a whole set of
different functional exercises and the
interesting thing about functional
exercises is there also fun they
decrease boredom and a lot of trainers
since the first edition of this book
came out or doing functional exercise
they're having people do all kinds of
things standing on this balance thing
pull do this you'll see a lot of it in
the gym some trainers really specialize
in it now if you want to sort of guide
your own strength program this book is
almost like a personal trainer doesn't
talk but it's got all the information
you need to guide a program and I'd say
if you read a lot of this stuff you know
more than most personal trainers
especially how to be safe doing this
stuff the best chapters in this book of
chapter five and six and 10 through 15
the 10 through 15 is the different
regions of your body that you could
focus on at different times anybody know
this picture that's up at Mount Baker on
the south side of Mount Baker someone's
named a3 tree lake but I don't think it
really has a name and I'm not going to
tell you exactly how to get there
because it is so beautiful and a nice
place to sit but it is the south side of
Mount Baker that's what I will tell you
if your energy level is low there's
other things that you want to do to try
to sort that out not thyroid test some
other things get your blood check for
anemia there's a lot of other things and
these are some things to strengthen your
energy if everything checks out okay
maybe your mitochondria are not getting
some things they need there are some
supplements that help mitochondria
including Co Q 10 and something called
l-carnitine these you all have coq10 in
your body you all have carnitine in your
body but these things can help your
cells make more energy and some people
take these things when they do vigorous
exercise or or training for something
the other thing is stress at your
adrenals is an inter
topic your adrenal glands are above your
kidneys and most people have never even
heard of the adrenal glands because all
they hear about is the thyroid make sure
your thyroids okay that's all they hear
about but did you know that adrenal
gland dysfunction is probably more
widespread than thyroid dysfunction do
you know why because of stress in
overtime we can damage our adrenal
glands ability to respond to stress now
what is stress to stress actually could
lead to increased cortisol temporarily
until you burn out and then you don't
have enough and you feel fatigued but
did you know that the stress that can
lead to increased cortisol also damages
your memory numerous studies have shown
that stress leading increased cortisol
damages the hippocampus in the brain
central part of the brain and that part
of the brain controls memory and I can't
tell you how many people have been
telling me I can't remember things as
well as I used to I go into room i'm not
sure why I'm there you know I mean
they're not they know what state they're
in and that kind of thing they know
they're in redmond when they're in
redmond but people's memories are
getting a little less good and it's
because of all the stress that we're
under the blood tests in general don't
evaluate the adrenal glands because in
order for the adrenal blood test to be
positive you got to almost be near
death's doorstep it's called Addison's
disease it doesn't evaluate it as well
so the best test that I've been able to
find for adrenal function is called the
adrenal stress index which actually
measures the salivary levels of adrenal
cortisol and test it over a day because
what's interesting is when you wake up
in the morning you should have the most
cortisol when you go to bed at night you
should have the least and there's a
circadian rhythm a 24-hour rhythm of
course all and if it's off things can be
off in your body you don't have enough
in the morning you won't want to get out
of bed you won't feel that good if you
have too much at night it's hard to go
to sleep so this could be something
that's helped healthy to test and
healthy to tune up few quick things and
will probably finish early not early but
I want to be able to take questions and
I usually do this I have so much
information and prepare more slides than
I have time for so do we have five
minutes or we like over
okay okay okay so how about your brain
how many people here want their brain to
work well and be efficient you know a
lot of people want more money that's a
pretty unit I want more money and I want
more time and I want to be happy but
what but you can accomplish these things
if your brain is functioning well that
helps you accomplish this better okay so
how's your memory and also how efficient
are you with cognitive processes and are
you a person that also has a little ADHD
your mind tends to wander you want to do
a little this and a little of that some
of us tend to do that when we're under
more stress you're forgetting things
frequently are you a sharp as you want
to be and when were you where you want
it to be with your brain function was
there a time back then you say yeah my
brain function was great now it isn't as
good anymore then there's the emotional
brain there's a great book that came out
called emotional intelligence by daniel
goleman who basically said you won't
have as much intelligence if your
emotional situation or your ability to
manage motions and keep yourself from
being triggered if you can't manage that
well it's going to preoccupy your mind
and take up too much of your RAM it's
unbelievable I you know how much ram do
you have in your brain I will tell you
we don't have enough we do not have
enough RAM in our brain it's a problem
you can't go to compusa or tech support
here and get more rent you go ID
somewhere on RAM for my brain put it
right in here please how do you know you
don't have enough RAM right now you go
I'm overloaded I can't think i maxed out
that tells you your Rams maxed out okay
what can max out your RAM is emotional
stuff going on where you're getting
triggered easily and upset and whatever
and one of the best books i found to
deal with this is called the feeling
good handbook by david burns he talks
about how to manage some of this stuff
on a day-to-day basis and the other
thing as good as the exercise helps to
manage it too but we didn't come with
instruction manuals nor do we come you
know in relationships with okay here's
your husband and wife and how they do
their emotions and how you do it so this
is a pretty complex subject I don't want
to say it's easy but our emotional
health is extremely important so the
ideal is good man
Murray good cognitive abilities being
able to focus really well being able to
multitask not having fatigue being
highly efficient and limiting your brain
inflammation and keeping emotionally
healthy that's what we want now here's
the picture of the brain the brain is
very complex there's neurotransmitters
up there there's synaptic connections in
these parts many parts of the brain that
are interrelated we have the blood-brain
barrier that's supposed to protect
things that we don't want getting into
the brain getting into the brain we want
to keep that bread blood brain barrier
healthy I talked about blueberries
omega-3s can help keep it healthy and
there's a great book on the blood-brain
barrier called the brain gate by Robert
ha Thurl which is very interesting about
this whole subject but how to keep your
brain healthy there's things that go out
on the cellular level that things that
go on in the neurotransmitter level and
there's these neurotransmitters that
basically make the signals and here's a
picture of neurotransmitters right at
the junction and places in your brain
there's a picture of how omega-3s can
work to augment neurotransmitters now B
vitamins and other things can work now
neurotransmitters are really critical
and it's really interesting because
you've all heard about serotonin I'm
sure you've heard about Prozac and
Zoloft and all those drugs too many
people are on those things why because
they're not happy okay and they're
depressed and their mood is down and
they don't know how to manage this so it
is interesting because if you exercise
regularly boot is improved but there's
ways to actually augment your serotonin
and some people do really well when they
take a little bit of an amino acid
called 5-htp in the morning it helps
augment their work their mood and they
think better some people don't have
enough energy and their mood is down and
they take an amino acid called
l-tyrosine they do better with that but
at any rate there's ways to evaluate and
improve your mood and your brain
functioning there's also things that can
actually improve your your memory your
sharpness of your memory not only gingko
but some other things that can actually
improve the sharpness of your memory so
I mentioned stress before it's really
important to manage stress because the
cortisol gets too high for
brain there's all kinds of things that
you can do to manage stress get enough
exercise sleep enough and then figure
out the things that you can do something
about like time management stress is the
worst thing if you're always late for
things or you got time deadlines that's
the worst dress then comes the financial
stress the relationships dress I say I'm
pretty good advising people about the
stuff in their body I'm not a financial
planner I'm not very good with my
organizational thing although do any of
you watch that that show The Apprentice
you can admit it you know I don't watch
it I don't usually watch it by my wife
watched it in order to visit with her
some time at home I have to go in and go
hi how you doing and then I get caught
up in this show so they I don't know if
any of you watch that episode where they
designed the organizational thing for
staples but now it's available so now if
you feel like you disorganize you can go
online staples to get the apprentice
desk organizer and help yourself with
stress from not knowing where things are
you know once things are a few inches in
your piles on your desk you probably
never see them so it helps to be
organized now I've got lots of
information in the slideshow about how
to prevent cancer how to prevent heart
disease and I want to just say because
this slide shall be available right how
do they they can email Tamra and they
can get the whole slide show okay so you
can read the rest of this because some
of this we don't have time to cover but
I do want to show you something here
this has more information about how to
eat limit inflammation I want to show
you something about blood vessels as you
can see on this slide this is a blood
vessel this is a blood vessel in your
brain and in your heart one year goals
after this lecture might be to keep my
arteries open keep your you might want
to have a you know have you ever seen a
bumper sticker that's to keep your
arteries open so we of course want to
keep the traffic lanes open around here
but at any rate here's the deal we
either gradually block off the arteries
from the way we eat and other things in
the free radicals and we get something
on the very end of this which is this
obstructive thing which causes problems
Oh
are the worst thing is we get this
plaque little bits of plaque in there
that you wouldn't think is narrow enough
to block that artery and then boom it
ruptures and blocks the whole thing
that's how you hear about these strokes
and these sudden heart attacks so one of
our goals is let's check out all the
risk factors for these arteries doing
these things and tune up all these rest
factors so you're at least you're at
least risk for plaque ruptures as well
as for the gradual closing off and need
any of you think that you don't get this
problem you all have it it's all there
they've studied teenagers in auto
accidents at age 17 and found this
plaque in their arteries we are all in a
process of plugging upper areas it's
just a matter of how much we have we
have to have a goal of managing it so
there's different things you can do to
evaluate the risk the most typical thing
again the average docs office is a
cholesterol check but that's very
limited because there's so many other
risk factors that have been found and so
I've listed these other risk factors
here not only the lipid panel but the
lipoprotein little a the homocysteine
the fibrinogen the CRP is the
inflammation markers someone asked me
about that that is and you want to keep
that less than three but the doctor has
to order what's called a cardio CRP
because otherwise they'll get a
different CR period has to be a cardio
CRP I'd recommend it being less than 1
the lab says less than three but you're
still at risk if it's between one and
three so I'd say less than one but
there's no drug you can take to get it
down you just got to manage your
inflammation like it was talking about
and these are other things the most
reasonable things to get are the lipid
panel the lipoprotein little a the
homocysteine fibrinogen and CRP those
are the most interesting things and
important but also your fasting glucose
to make sure you're not developing
diabetes and something called the
hemoglobin a1c and then all these things
can be tuned up with either exercise
nutrients and rarely drugs drugs do not
need to be used that often to actually
tune these things up unless you have
hereditary genetic conditions and then
the only the drugs are only available
actually to tune up the cholesterol at
any rate I got
lot more information about each one of
these things about heart disease and
cholesterol and I think what we'll do is
just flip to the end here so a few
things I'd say learning about your
health and investing yourself has really
high returns you know the stock market
doesn't have as high returns now neither
does you can't really get a CD I mean I
got a CD recently at wells fargo was 3.5
percentage oh this is unbelievable but
that still isn't that good but believe
or not money you actually spend for your
health in case you didn't know it
occasionally your health plan is not
going to cover some things that does
happen they don't cover you to go to the
grocery store pick healthier food so you
sometimes have to invest in your health
but it really has a huge payoff the
knowledge and the health things that you
do having new health goals is important
and I say to people hey every week do a
little something until you're at a place
where you say I'm doing all that I can
do that's reasonable to be as healthy in
my brain and my body as possible this
book will help you for the exercise in
the first three parts and the part 4 for
information about supplements and diet
and I'll be around if you have any
questions do we want to do questions as
a group or just have people come up and
ask questions okay
okay does anybody have any question I
had a question about organic cereals
versus the fortified more mass market
cereals and the fact that you can't
really get as much of the fortification
in the organic cereals and that's kind
of an issue in terms of vitamins and
minerals oh okay what the source is is
better see ya well I'll tell you what
the Journal of the American Medical
Association in 2002 actually suggested
that the average American take a
multivitamin and one of the reasons was
because of the b-vitamin issues and some
other things and so I recommend that
people look for their breakfast cereal
primarily for fiber and the taste and
some other things and you actually can
now get fortified organic cereals or
fortified natural you can actually not
quite like total which had quote a
hundred percent of the minimum daily
requirements but you know but I do
suggest people take a really good
multivitamin to meet the needs not only
the antioxidants but the B vitamins and
so I don't know that you can necessarily
look for a serial that would do that for
you but you know there's so many cereals
that are out there that you can probably
choose a healthy cereal that has some
fortification in there any other
question
with regard to some of the alternative
forms of medicine yeah homeopathics and
turn things of that nature they've done
any studies on before engaging have any
information on how those play into your
overall plan
well i would say that acupuncture is
things like acupuncture primarily used
for treating certain things and i don't
know of any studies that look at it as a
preventative mode homeopathy is
interesting it's the use of very dilute
substances to treat things there have
been studies done treating particular
things but I don't know of any studies
that say that sort of evaluating and
treating with homeopathy helps wellness
there are some people to do homeopathy
that would say that but I don't know any
any skypes so the most studies have been
done in regard to exercise diet
nutrition stress those are where the
most studies have been done i can i can
tell you anecdotally about something
some of the alternative treatments but
not in terms of research-based talk
about muscle mass and building it up
reasonably and how that if I understood
correctly can positively affect
metabolism correct okay so so is a
relationship there you also hear kind of
conventional wisdom that you say as you
get older you lose you lose muscle mass
right as you get older your meat out
metabolism naturally slow so that's all
kind of correlated to each other as you
get older you lose muscle mass and the
tablets can slow your resting metabolic
break and go down that's why people
getting lady's ears they it
you know a lot of people save GOI I was
eating the same stuff before but once I
passed the age of 35 this little thing
came on there and then it you know so
trickier trying to figure out which
messages you hear in the media you know
it makes sense and is accurate changes
frequently yeah what the current
thinking is is there give any
recommendations on a place to get
information that's tends to be stapler
more reliable or how do we how do you
deal with all this well what what I
would say is this that you got diet
books coming out regularly because diet
books make a lot of money if they get
popular okay so that's going to happen
them if somebody's get and most of them
are twists on the same thing what I
tried to do in my book which was coming
up until November and nothing's changed
that much except some new food pyramids
came out but I was in touch with the
research on the new food pyramids
because because I heard lectures by
Walter Willett from Harvard who was
instrumental in the new food pyramids
they tip they turn a lot of the food
pyramid is upside down not only this is
there a new one but there's a number of
them now and there's information I'd hot
hot meal which is what might one of my
email accounts had that on the other day
about the new food pyramids or something
so I recommend you look at that chapter
26 in my book takes a lot of the diets
and tries to synthesize what has been
constant over time metabolically good
for people because the main things are
what's good for cancer prevention what's
good for blood vessel prevention what's
good for brain function and I
synthesized a lot i looked at every
single diet out there and then there's
websites in there there's a lot of
websites in there and you know there's
some government websites and I could I'd
be foolish to tell you that you know
there's a place that you can look for
the next few years it's just going to be
constant there's but i will say a lot of
this stuff on omega threes has been
constant for years now the low carb carb
thing that gets debated a lot and it
really has there's individual you all
have biochemistry biochemical
individuality some some people say i do
better on a low-carb diet some people
say
better than this but everybody needs
adequate protein so there's certain
things that I talked about and that are
in there pretty stable yeah and what's
your being on the msn yeah mesum I just
wrote a chapter in a book on this stone
and MSM important doesn't have enough
research articles to support that it's
helpful so I can't advocate it studies
have shown actually a chondroitin is
health helpful I just don't like the
source of how windpipes you know there
is there's a store called natures pantry
in bellevue that has a source of
chondroitin from shellfish it's called
low molecular weight control names
healthier it's also pricier trader joe
has one feels cold joint support
exclusively oh good cool gee I have a
question about
what your take is on things like fasting
and cleanses and colonics as a thank-you
either to kick-start a healthier
lifestyle or to do as a yearly basis
that's a big topic and i don't i don't
know that i can answer it well in front
of the class but i'd say i don't agree
with fasting because if you don't
support biotransformation in your body
and you just go without eating and drink
water you're not you're not going to do
too well so people used to advocate
complete fast and just drinking water
and I don't advocate that I advocating
at least getting certain level of
protein and nutrients I'll tell you it
works great for people who have food
allergies because then they stop eating
the foods they're sensitive to but it's
better to get blood tests on that and
see what that is but that's a big topic
I'd rather talk to you about it
privately because it's it's not a short
answer any other yeah you mentioned
Walter bulletin i'm sure you're familiar
with this book a new versions coming out
he advocated a little bit of a low
glycemic diet yeah ah yeah whole grains
verses and he's put two refined flours
like an even wheat bread type stuff in
the same category as yeah you know
Candis and stuff like that yeah what is
he's talking a lot about insulin
sensitivity I didn't even get into them
but one goal is to maintain your body's
sensitivity to your own insulin because
you don't want to become type 2 diabetic
or develop what's called the metabolic
syndrome so a lot of his research some
well some of his research is based on
that so he's talking about low glycemic
index foods and he's also talking about
limiting the things are going to just
jump your blood sugar up and I think
it's very reasonable you know did you I
will grant dude harder to come by yeah
and what I would say is this that you
don't have to be too uptight about it
that the better way to do it is to say
okay I'm going to choose healthier
carbohydrates I'm not going to worry too
much about Lee eating low glycemic index
so that I've got a I got it I got a
whole thing on glycemic index I got a
website in here about even look up the
glycemic index of anything you start
doing that though it just is to
definitely go G I'm only going to eat
things up to advise you mechanics a 70
you go nuts it's been
to eat the healthier brains and
carbohydrates and you know I would say
you know the cliff bars are pretty
reasonable that way in terms of glycemic
index and you can eat reasonable vice
Simic index and not have to spend too
much time thinking about it I have a
bunch of stuff in here both in the
sports nutrition chapter regular chapter
about about that issue and how to do it
without getting too crazy about
hydration recommendations well people
need to be well hydrated and that gets
into the whole issue of what is pure
water and that sort of thing because but
you know people need fluids and you
don't want to have dark urine all day
long that means you're somewhat low in
fluids so you know it's been said about
six to eight glasses of fluid per day
doesn't have to all be water I recommend
using filtered water and limiting
plastics there's a whole bunch of
information about that but um and having
you know a filter that you use at home
but six to eight glasses of fluid a lot
of it may be water it's quite reasonable
so you're not like low on the fluid
every day I can understand to get high
retention and fall can be detrimental
yeah increases your chances of
yeah but if you don't have hypertension
you salt bad for you well you need salt
I mean you're talking about sodium
fluoride right you need some salt too
much of it it's too much fast for you we
already said too much so by definition
in your linguistics it probably isn't 50
um so you know I would say this that
some people are used to taking a salt
salt shaker in every meal it's just
going on there that's probably not a
good idea but you know there are these
types of salts that have like sea salt
could be healthy the ayodhya denies salt
we need iodine for thyroid function so
uh so I would say in general that if
your conservative with the salt you're
probably going to be okay as long as you
don't have hypertension I mean and the
other thing is if you go hiking hot
weather you need some salt so I'd
recommend you know getting the bags of
mixed nuts and Gorp that have some salt
in it as opposed to the null salt stuff
you're going to be out on all day long
activity yeah we're going elk along
closest appliances
well the main thing about alcohol
consumption is it can damage your brain
cells and they can damage you liver and
so and then again red wine has been
shown to have some phytochemicals it can
be somewhat healthy in terms of your HDL
but I don't recommend people use up
because there's lots of ways to get your
phytochemicals without damaging the
brain you live so you know an occasional
glass of of you know alcoholic beverages
but you know some people are doing you
know a beer every night two beers every
night five on the weekend and it's just
it's a cost-benefit analysis there it's
not good for you what we do have any
advice for like tendonitis or tendon
thing yeah but that's very specific to
where your tendon is
yeah what like a elbows from like
climbing or something like that it's
still very specific because I don't want
to give you tendinitis advice about your
elbows when everybody is sitting in here
listening but come up to me afterwards
and we cannot briefly I can't do
position set on the outside of my clinic
well supplements you know supplements
are not you know enough protein is real
important that's the main thing but
supplements are not as helpful for
tendonitis unless there's things like
ginger and curcumin their natural
anti-inflammatories that will decrease
tendinitis a little bit but the joint
support supplements have been shown by
numerous research studies to support the
cartilage in the joints but there
haven't been any really good pendants
support supplements so there's a lot of
other ways to get the tendinitis I wish
I could tell you it was a tenant support
supplement but maybe if we develop it
you can make millions of dollars yeah
let's go ahead and finish there and if
you have any more place yeah you can
come up and talk